so let me start by saying
congratulations on the movie
um i am curious what is it like then
for you like the night before you're
gonna maybe meet
matt damon and tom for the first time to
possibly talk about the movie
you know before you were officially
signed on if you will i i don't know how
it all worked
but what is it like for you the night
before you're going to meet people like
that are you in your head a little bit
you know so i i it was in
different steps first i had to drink
with tom
and the two co-writers and then
i hoped i would be given the opportunity
to audition
but no news during a month a month and a
half so i thought
and i hadn't read the movie by then uh
so i thought oh
okay well no i'm not auditioning and
then
a month and a half after they sent me
the script
and i could audition and then i started
working
really hard and
to be honest the work was to get into
that story
as as as much as i could believe like i
remember i had to audition
the scene when he comes in and i had i
even tried to
see the furniture the kitchen imagine
everything my apartment my life in
marseille
tried to come with as much material as i
could
from the story to be in my mind so that
and then when i met tom when i
auditioned he was here
and then we worked together for an hour
and it was great i
i really enjoyed the audition i was
really stressed
but at the same time working with tom
was
fantastic because it was it was
you know tommy's an actor and i think
he's done a lot of theater and i've done
a lot of theater too like the character
i come from
theater um so it really reminded me like
the rehearsals when you really sweat
and tried to find something and and i
thought when i came out i thought all
right it might not be me
it doesn't depend on me but the moment i
was happy because i thought i
i i i had you know
i've done what i could and and and then
i enjoyed the moment
and then i was confirmed and then i met
matt
and then yes i had trouble falling
asleep and
and then uh it took me a little while to
relax but uh the thing is
as he he his performance is incredible
he disappeared behind bill baker
so i at matt damon i just you know
had a vague memory of matt damon but
he disappeared yeah he's what we call a
talented actor
um yeah yeah we could call him that
yeah exactly i'm just gonna go with that
um i love learning about the behind the
scenes
uh of the making of a movie what do you
think might surprise people to learn
about the making of stillwater
well honestly i i was often asked is it
so what do you think about working in an
american movie is it really different
and it wasn't
it was really like so close to well like
for example if you like the behind the
scene matt damon
is it like a very how does he behave as
a hollywood star
so when we were shooting in my flats we
had the other flats
being like for the green room and also
where the monitors were
so tom was just in this little room with
his monitor
and then matt his green room was a
kitchen a very tiny kitchen
and you could only have one chair in it
and it was all long so he was sitting on
a high
high chair and the door was always open
and then
you had like his friends from hair and
and makeup standing there but they
couldn't even
sit and so we were very far away from
the
the image that we have of a movie star
you know he was very simple uh one of
the things i think that adds to this
film
uh is that you guys shot on location
there were no sound stages
um you know and i think that adds so
much to the movie uh can you sort of
talk about
filming on location and what that you
know what that meant to you
yes of course uh i think marseille is a
character
and she's it's one of the main character
of the movie
and so the way he filmed marseille was
just so
it was realistic and artistic and
and at the same time the for example in
our flat the setting
it was the ambience in the flat the
atmosphere was
was filled with the mediterranean energy
and it really helped
and um so
definitely we were all
filled with the energy of the city and
and
and the actors there were a lot of local
actors lilu she lives in marseille
uh renault also he lives in the south of
france
musa there are many actors who who live
there so
it definitely helped um feeling it was a
reality
completely uh uh i am what we call
excited
for uh some movie called um the house of
gucci i think it was made by
ridley scott i think i'm familiar i
think he's made some movies before
um yeah can you sort of talk about
getting to work with another really
gifted director and what that experience
was like
yeah it was it was really it was really
a beautiful experience and then i
again my partners were quite impressive
and i think they they've delivered
amazing performances
i can't wait to see the movie because i
think they are going to be very
impressive
yeah i saw um i was able to talk to
ridley when he was in italy
and he showed me it was not just me but
he showed his italian villa where he was
put up with these
statues and it just looked like he was
having the time of his life he's so
energetic about everything
he is yes he's yeah you just described
it perfectly he has
a pleasure that is like pure
pure pleasure and joy of doing what he
does
which is impressive because his energies
beyond what we can imagine completely my
last question for you um about
stillwater
one of the things that i really love
about about tom's work is that
his dialogue just feels authentic and
real it doesn't feel like it's out of
some hollywood movie can you sort of
talk about uh
just the dialogue and the script and the
quality of the writing
it's funny because i it was speaking
english speaking french was just
didn't really matter because the
dialogues were so close to
what was happening between the
characters that
they were they became uh
just it's not it's not a dialect that
that sometimes words can be obstacles
but they were
just um tools
i would say sure um
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say congrats on the movie i wish you
nothing but the best thank you for your
time
thank you bye-bye